foreign
yes sir all right bring your head out
here just a little bit okay I'll tip my
finger with your eyes
man how much you had a drink literally
nothing I took my friend home all right
I'm Gonna Get You Out make sure you're
okay drive okay
yeah your tags are expired as well I
know that already I work for Cincinnati
you work for Cincinnati and you got you
guys I showed you my badge I know but
I'm saying you work for Cincinnati and
you're driving around with expired tags
how long you work for
about a year and a half I started when I
graduated college all right I'll have
you walk through the passenger side of
my vehicle you said walk to the path yes
what do you want me to start just just
walk back there just walk down just walk
yeah okay yeah I I didn't know if you
were doing that if you're doing the the
step test or whatever no I'm gonna do
hcn first and we'll go from there
stand by my front tire there
[Applause]
where do you live at you said what where
do you live at I'm literally going home
I shot my friend though okay we're at my
friend's house okay cool
all right just stand right here face out
towards me all right have you followed
tip this pin with your eyes only don't
need your head at all okay getting a
recent head natural back injuries my
neck hurts yes neck hurts you have any
issues with your knees my knees hurt yes
too yes sir take any prescriptions no
sir seeing a doctor for anything no so
glasses or contacts nope diabetic or
epileptics nope all right Paul tip is
Count Your Eyes
[Music]
you can blink at any time okay
okay you know the process man I know I
know I know I know the process like I
Know It All right so you know I gotta
hold it out there for too long
foreign
there's nothing to drink at all no sir
so if you pull in a portable broadcast
it'd be troubled I refuse all that you
can call your sergeant if you want to I
don't need to call myself I'm just
saying but like I literally have had
nothing to drink nothing to drink and it
might be triple zeros right
you mean you both know how it goes I
know how it goes yeah me too and you've
been drinking I have not you have I can
still smell it on you as you're talking
you cannot smell anything on me
smells stronger than alcohol coverage
you cannot I can okay why would I make
it up why would I pull you out of the
car I have no idea I was speeding yes if
you want an army speeding ticket and uh
ticket for my life for my registration
be expired fine that's fine okay but
you're not willing for an important no
sir I want to put you through some more
time I refuse you refuse go ahead and
turn around
what test went around I would do the
test
us now I will do the test
I really just want to why why are you
trying to you know how this goes I know
how it goes that's that's why I'm asking
why you're doing this like I want to get
because I smell alcohol I'm doing I'm
doing my job okay I will do it you want
me to walk in the long way no no just
don't walk away right here I start
started the line you wanna you wanna
walk on the crack of this line right
here whatever you want me to do that
that is obviously uneven pavement no I'm
gonna have you walk in front of my car
okay let's fuck
walk up here how many steps walk up just
walk regular not one foot in front of
the other no but I'll explain it when
you get up here I'm gonna have you walk
towards my car okay so just walk regular
yes that's what I just said you're not
listening no I know how stop right there
that's why I asked turn towards my car
okay
all right so can you imagine a line
going from here to my patrol car can I
yes I will sure you can use this this
line right here this black line that's
like another you can yeah so you can do
that okay all right so I'm gonna get you
a starting position stay in that
position so I tell you to start test yes
sir all right gonna put your left foot
on the line with your right foot in
front touching heel toe
with your right foot in front touching
heel toe right foot in front okay
Kyoto arms out your side stay in that
position until I tell you to start what
you're going to do is take nine Hill toe
steps down the line this is I don't know
if I can take nine sets but I will try
they're going to be Heel To Toe steps
you'll be able to take nine Hill toe
steps all right unless you got Shaquille
O'Neal's feet you'll be fine and they
don't look like Shaquille O'Neal's feet
so nine he'll toe steps down that line
once you get down that line you're going
to keep your lead foot on the ground
take a series of small steps turn around
and take nine Hill toe steps back you
want to demonstrate it Maria the whole
time you do it you'll count your steps
out loud stay looking down your feet
keep your arms out your sides and once
you start the test you're not stop it's
gonna look just like so
you're gonna go one two three I took
three sets you're gonna take nine keep
the Sleep foot on the ground series
small steps turn around nine heel toe
stabs back the other way one two three I
took three steps you're gonna take nine
yes sir you understand everything
check's okay you can go ahead and begin
a test one
two
three
four
five
six seven eight
[Applause]
can I come back now yeah okay one two
one two three four
six
seven eight nine
all right turn towards my car
feet together
arms on our sides same thing it'll start
till I tell you two what you're gonna do
is raise the other foot off the ground
six inches You're Gonna Keep your legs
straight with your toes pointed out
the whole time you do it you're going to
count in this manner one thousand one
one thousand two one thousand three so
on and so forth so I tell you stop as
you know the test last 30 seconds I
toggle with my watch okay the whole time
you do it you'll count in the manner I
just instructed you'll stay looking down
at the foot that you have raised and
you'll keep your arms down at your side
just gonna look just like so either put
you like one thousand one one thousand
two one thousand three one thousand four
one thousand five see how my legs
straight yeah those pointed out arms and
exercise do that the whole time okay let
me know when you're ready do you
understand the instructions I understand
all right you can go to begin test
one thousand one one thousand two one
thousand three one thousand four one
thousand five one thousand six one
thousand seven one thousand eight one
thousand nine one thousand ten One
Thousand Eleven two thousand twelve 2013
2014 2015 2016 2017
2018 2019 2020 1021 2022 1023 1024 1025
2026. I can't my balance is off all
right that's 30 seconds yeah go put your
hands behind your back Are you seriously
yes sir you're under arrest property
vehicle in here put the phone together
bring your arms back
do you need another set what'd you say
you need two sets on no I don't you
don't I don't take your watch off put
your pocket full
this is a Rolex all right put it in your
pocket I don't want
any possession to Rolex
it's almost good
so it's your girlfriend yeah
should've been drinking too no just
shoot yep all right well I haven't been
drinking but my friends been drinking I
can think I could use this question
whatsoever all right this is too tight
no all right